want to see something really scary the
horror genre is especially fertile
ground for Easter eggs because it's
always unnerving to discover something
hiding in plain sight here are a few
particularly ominous Easter eggs hidden
in some of your favorite horror films
potential spoilers ahead
many people consider 1973 The Exorcist
to be one of the finest horror films
ever made sure some of the scares and
effects might not pack the same punch
they once did particularly after decades
of parody and imitations nevertheless
the Exorcist still manages to unnerve
audiences all these years later to add
to the unease director William Friedkin
included all sorts of subliminal sounds
and images speaking with Entertainment
Weekly he discussed the layering sounds
deep into the film's mix like the
buzzing of bees
[Music]
Friedkin hope such effects would trigger
an unconscious fight-or-flight response
in the viewer to that end freaking also
inserted a frightening face into a few
shots and they're just fast enough for
you to register that something freaky is
afoot sure the face looks a lot less
impressive once you get a close look at
it but thanks to some stealth editing
it's an admittedly creepy effect John
Carpenter's The Thing features some
impressive practical creature effects
and a slow burn plot that still has
people questioning the nd this 80's cult
classic stars Kurt Russell is a
helicopter pilot fighting against a
shape-shifting alien on a remote base
camp and Antarctica yes it's as awesome
as it sounds the thrills come from
watching the dwindling research team try
to determine which of their suppose it
peers is actually the creature that's no
small feat considering the alien can
mimic anything it touches here's the
thing though if they'd known how to
speak Norwegian the team could have
avoided their predicament altogether at
the beginning of the film a dog runs
toward the team and a clearly
traumatized man is trying to shoot the
creature
he's passionately shouting something but
it's not the language that any of the
researchers understand
according to some translations the man
is shouting something along the lines of
get the hell out of there that's not a
dog it's some sort of thing it's
imitating a dog it isn't real get away
you idiots they probably wouldn't have
believed him anyway but it's still
rather chilling to know the plots is all
laid out in the film's opening moments
the 2004 horror film saw totally cleaned
up at the box office earning almost a
hundred times its 1.2 million dollar
budget the reveal of jigsaws identity is
a real shocker but eagle-eyed fans could
have figured it out much sooner if
they'd noticed one subtle detail early
on in the film we meet one of dr.
Gordon's cancer patients a fellow by the
name of John Kramer at one point we see
Kramer resting in his hospital bed and
savvy viewers might have noticed an
intriguing drawing on a page of his
sketchbook yes it's a drawing of the
infamous Reverse bear trap you know the
one
the sketch is a nice touch that's sure
to appeal to obsessive horror fans life
is all about enjoying the little things
isn't it most people
Pennywise the dancing clown is creepy no
matter how you slice it
both in Stephen King's gargantuan horror
novel it's and in the stellar two-part
film adaptation in fact the movie
includes one particularly chilling
detail from King's novel penny wise can
change the color of his eyes at will
considering all the other things he's
capable of like you know transforming
into a physical manifestation of your
greatest fear this might not seem like
such a big deal it's why he does it that
really makes your skin crawl at the
beginning of it chapter 1 Georgie has a
famously ill-fated encounter with penny
wise and you might have noticed that the
clown's eyes suddenly change from yellow
to blue that comes directly from a
passage of King's novel there were
yellow eyes in there the sort of eyes he
had always imagined but never actually
seen down in the basement a few
paragraphs later King writes now George
wondered could I have thought his eyes
were yellow they were a bright dancing
blue the color of his mom's eyes
Pennywise realizes Georgie is about to
run away so he changes the color of his
eyes to mirror Georgie's loved ones
therefore putting the boy at ease how
insidious of him the conjuring 2 plays a
fun game of peekaboo throughout the film
the demons named Ballack is subtly
sprinkled throughout various scenes
always hiding somewhere in the
background for instance it's written
here on the kitchen wall the V comes
from the love knick-knack sitting on top
it's also here on the bookshelf there
are five wooden letters spread out
across the shelves the next time you
check out the conjuring 2 you're
cordially invited to play a game we like
to call where's Valek for instance you
can also see the name spelled out in the
beaded necklace Lorraine's daughter is
making let's see if you can spot it
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite horror movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]